Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Okay, today's Maestro Hook.
This Hook you can use with businessmen when you're having a conversation with Westerners...
...to get an interesting conversation going.
So, there's an interesting story.
There were two groups of businessmen, one Western and one Japanese.
And their boss gave them two same projects at the same time.
The project is exactly the same.
The Westerners immediately started delegating and said, "You do this, you do that,"...
...and started getting to work.
And the Japanese group started exchanging business cards for the first 30 minutes.
Which group do you think finished that meeting first?
So, you might think the Westerners. But, no.
Actually, they both finished at the same time.
What it means is that Japanese people and Western people have a different way of doing business,...
...but don't get so caught up 'cause the result is usually the same.
So, today's Maestro Menu.
What's on the agenda?
What's on the agenda today?
Okay.
First things first.
What's on the agenda today?
Okay, first things first,...
...let's talk about everyone's responsibility.
Okay. So, in a situation like this, Maestro Lines.
Okay, what's on today's agenda?
Okay, we have a full-packed day today.
So, everyone's gonna be busy.
What's on today's agenda?
Okay, first things first, let's talk about the budget.
Okay. That's it for today and thanks a lot.
And see you again on Native Maestro.
Bye-bye.